one more question does anyone think
putin would be amassing you know a
hundred thousand plus troops on the
border with ukraine threatening war if
donald trump was still in office i tend
to doubt that be happening nor do i
think he would have gotten the waiver on
the north stream two pipeline but then
again the trump family never made
millions of dollars with russian
oligarchs like the biden family and zero
experience hunter did now earlier today
south carolina senator lindsey graham
met with the former president who was on
with us last night he joins us now with
more
i see that ad and i'll be honest i think
the observation of your colleague rand
paul is not too far off and that is
maybe we should keep him away from
cameras and microphones because it's
really bad
yeah i mean the news conference was a
disaster on multiple levels but it's not
the news conference uh he's been on the
world stage joe biden for 40 years he
was in charge of the ukraine uh
portfolio under the biden the obama
administration so everybody in the
ukraine understands that joe biden
didn't realize his own son was serving
on the beresma board the most corrupt
gas company in the world
while biden was trying to clean up uh
corruption so i talked with president
trump today about this
he's he's pretty floored like i am you
know at a certain level we all we all
want to pull for the for the president
that that we could do better with covid
that we would make the world a safer
place so putin realizes that under biden
he can invade the ukraine and get away
with it he realized that under trump he
could not invade the ukraine and get
away with it but here's what president
trump said to me today that was pretty
pretty stunning and i think appropriate
he said
putin is
realizing that bine's weak but he
doesn't realize that biden won't be
around in 2024 so president trump said
today if they invade the ukraine
the russians it will make it impossible
for any future president to have a
normal relationship with russia which i
thought was a pretty damn wise
observation yeah by the way i'm looking
at what looks like a band-aid on your
nose now president trump didn't pop it
he didn't give it pop in the nose did he
no that's bernie sanders he didn't hit
you with a golf ball or anything if you
played golf with them
look he's right in his observations and
biden is a disaster
and
if you want to take out russia to me
it's easy and it's all related something
that's good for our national security
and that is energy independence and it
also is good to stop the 40-year high in
inflation because every every price of
every item we buy will go down because
it will cost less to ship it
and we'll pay less at the pump less to
cool and heat our homes and that would
be the one way out if i wanted to take
on china and stop their territorial
ambitions with for example taiwan i
would just
form a coalition and stop all importing
from china that'll shut them down pretty
quick as well because that's both of
their economies right there hanging in
the balance
yeah i mean
russia is exposed it's a it's a gas
station parading as a country so energy
independence for us weakens russia uh
the day that america doesn't have to
worry about the mideast in terms of oil
and gas is a great day china is very
much connected to the global economy and
when trump threatened to put tariffs on
chinese products they changed when trump
told mexico if you don't help me secure
our border i'll put tariffs on your
product products coming out of mexico
they change so
strength words weakness doesn't but
here's my message to president biden you
claim that no republican wants to help
you that's not true you got to do things
that we can help you with why don't we
put sanctions on russia now for the uh
for the buildup not the invasion all
democratic sanctions hit russia after an
invade let's punish putin now and why
don't we do a lend lease bill like
senator cornyn has doing for the
ukrainians what we did for the british
in the early stages of world war ii
endless weapons to to make sure they're
a bunch of dead russians if you invade
ukraine
biden cannot adjust his policies on
energy he can't adjust his policies on
borders because of the the left he can't
adjust his policies on the ukraine but
we're running out of time i agree
senator good to see you